eine zusammenarbeit ist natürlich immer
machen zwei sind immer stärker als einer
allein dazu kommt das natürlich nicht
nur die sprache sondern auch die
geschichte und sozusagen lange zeit
nebeneinander gesehen hat und
miteinander gesehen hat das ist klar das
ist für uns deutsche das land ist mit
dem wir am ehesten zu einer
zusammenarbeit kommen weil wir kulturell
politisch und sprachlich im grunde
genommen 1 sind wir sehen auf
europäischer ebene
das ist enorm viel handlungsbedarf auch
in zukunft ergeben wir die migrations
krise ist keineswegs vom tisch
das sehen wir ja auch mit irgendwelchen
deals die mit einem türkischen
machthaber getroffen werden
die 1 in nur das erpressungspotenzial
beinhalten wir haben uns von anfang an
dagegen ausgesprochen lieber diese
milliarden die wir einem türkischen
diktator hinterher schießen in einen
effektiven grenzschutz und in ein
effektives klein schutz regime zu
investieren
denn wir sehen auf europäischer ebene
ist frontex gescheitert es wird immer
nur herum elaboriert die europäischen
führungsspitzen ergehen sich einen sitz
kreisen ohne in irgendeiner art und
weise effektive ergebnisse vorzeigen zu
können
das sehen wir eben frontex ist immer
noch nicht auf der spur
im jahr 2026 soll dann noch mal eine
bewertung über frontex auf europäischer
ebene ergehen und im endergebnis ist
doch ganz klar wir haben überhaupt gar
keinen effektiven grenzschutz wir haben
offene grenzen nach wie vor und wir
haben überall beschleuniger auch
innerhalb des europäischen rechtssystem
weil dublin 2 bzw 3 gebrochen wird dann
wird er jetzt schon der weg auf gemacht
für sogenannte klimaflüchtlinge auch
diesem problem müssen wir uns annehmen
und wir haben allein nur in diesem
themenfeld was ich gerade aufgerissen
habe gezeigt dass hier gewaltige
probleme auf uns zukommen die durch
diese gesamte klimadebatte die aus
meiner sicht eine riesige grüne kampagne
ist finanziert durch internationale
fonds überdeckt wird und die mit noch
stärkerer kraft auf uns zurollen wird
und dementsprechend werden wir uns
abstimmen müssen
und das tun wir auch gerne so wie wir
das leben schon auf europäischer ebene
tun und wir werden das alle sehen vor
allen dingen sie auch was da auf uns
zukommen wird und wir bereiten uns
darauf vor auf die themenfelder denn die
regierungen in europa sind dazu nicht
fähig und das beweisen sie gerade um ein
weiteres mal